BUT FIRST, MEDIA, NOT TRUMP,
FUMBLED THE G7.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WATCHING THE AMERICAN MEDIA
COVERAGE OF G7, I CAN'T HELP BUT
THINK THEY CAN'T GO ANY LOWER OR
BE A MORE UNINFORMED OR MORE
DISHONEST.
>> WHAT IF ANYTHING DO YOU THINK
THE PRESIDENT ACCOMPLISHED AT
THE G7 SUMMIT?
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR ANYTHING.
THE PRESIDENT WASN'T LEADING AT
THIS G7 SUMMIT BUT HE WAS
MISLEADING.
>> WITH MORE OF A G6 PLUS ONE.
>> Laura: BRILLIANT ANALYSIS.
THE INDISPUTABLE FACT IS THAT
AMERICA UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS AN ECONOMY THAT IS THE ENVY
OF THE WORLD.
BUT IT'S AS IF ON CUE, THE PRESS
FINDS A WAY TO FRAME THINGS IN
THE WORST POSSIBLE LIGHT AGAINST
TRUMP.
BUT HERE IS WHAT YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
NUMBER ONE, CHINA IS COMING BACK
TO THE TRADE NEGOTIATING TABLE
ALL BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S TARIFF.
NUMBER TWO, THE WHITE HOUSE AND
JAPAN ARE NEGOTIATING A NEW
TRADE DEAL ON AGRICULTURE AND
BEEF.
IT WILL BE GREAT FOR AMERICAN
FARMERS.
NUMBER THREE, THE U.K. WANT TO
TRADE DEAL.
THEY WILL HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
AFTER THE BREXIT DEAL IS SETTLED
TO GET IT.
NUMBER FOUR, THE E.U. IS FACING
HUGE POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS.
AND AT NUMBER FIVE, WE HAVE THE
STRONGEST ECONOMY BAR NONE IN
THE G7.
YET PETER BAKER, A PENDANT
MASQUERADING AS A JOURNALIST WAS
SO DESPERATE THAT HE MEASURED
THE MEETING SUCCESS ON THE
NUMBER OF WORDS IN THE FINAL
STATEMENT THAT CAME OUT FOR THE
G7.
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENCES WITH
TRUMP, THEY LARGELY HAD A
STATEMENT THAT ADDED UP TO 264
WORDS.
14,263 WORDS.
INTERNATIONAL BUREAUCRATS, THEY
TALK A LOT AND RIGHT A LOT A
LOT, MEANINGLESS BLATHER.
AND THAT WAS BACK IN 2016 OF
COURSE WHEN THE U.S. ECONOMY WAS
LIMPING ALONG AND CHINA WAS
EATING OUR LUNCH.
DO YOU WANT THAT OR DO YOU WANT
A SHORT G7 STATEMENT ESPECIALLY
COMPARED TO THE FRENCH, THE
GERMAN AND THE BRITISH.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS AN EASY
CALL.
THE FACT THAT MAJOR EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES ARE IN THE ECONOMIC
TURMOIL, IT'S NOT OUR FAULT.
IT'S THEIRS.
THEY STAKED THEIR FUTURES ON A
EUROPEAN UNION THAT WAS FLAWED
FROM THE INCEPTION.
THEY WERE OVER REGULATING THEIR
BUSINESSES AND OVERTAXING THEIR
PEOPLE AND THEY ALLOWED IN OVER
A MILLION REFUGEES OF VERY
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS AND VERY
DIFFERENT VALUES.
AND THE MEDIA SOMEHOW THINK
TRUMP SHOULD FOLLOW THEIR LEAD.
I DON'T THINK SO.
TRUMP HAD THE GUTS TO DO A
SERIOUS REVIEW AND REVISION OF
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
I'M TALKING BOTH POLICIES.
>> CHINA HAS TAKEN A VERY HARD
HIT OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
MONTHS.
THEY'VE LOST 3 MILLION JOBS,
SHOULDN'T BE MORE THAN 3 MILLION
JOBS.
THE CHAIN IS BREAKING LIKE
NOBODY HAS SEEN BEFORE AND ONCE
THAT HAPPENS IT'S VERY HARD TO
PUT IT BACK TOGETHER, YOU
UNDERSTAND.
I THINK THEY VERY MUCH WANT TO
MAKE A DEAL AND THE LONGER THEY
WAIT THE HARDER IT IS TO PUT IT
BACK.
IF IT CAN BE PUT BACK AT ALL.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT IS
BEING VERY CRAFTY HERE AND VERY
PRAGMATIC.
HE STILL WILLING TO WORK A DEAL
WITH THE CHINESE, YET HE IS NOT
GOING TO AGREE TO ANYTHING IF IT
RETURNS THE UNITED STATES TO THE
STATUS QUO.
BEFORE HE CAME INTO OFFICE,
WHERE CHINA JUST CHEATED
RAMPANTLY AND THEY GOT STRONGER
AND STRONGER AT OUR EXPENSE YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR.
HE'S NOT GOING TO AGREE TO THAT.
YET, THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY TAKING
THE WORD OF THIS OPPRESSIVE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT OVER THAT
OF THEIR OWN COUNTRY'S
PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE EVEN GONE TOO FAR FOR
CNBC'S JIM CRAMER.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO TAKEN
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE HE CAN WALK
BACK ON ANYTHING YOU SAID.
YOU COULD HAVE THE CHINESE
OFFICIALLY DENYING IT IN THE
CHINESE HAVEN'T NECESSARILY BEEN
SQUARE AND HONEST.
SUDDENLY WE BELIEVE THE CHINESE
ARE HONEST.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE WOULD'VE
RATHER TAKE THE WORD OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
>> I'M AGHAST THAT WE TRUST THE
PRC MORE THAN WE TRUST THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: I LOVE JOE KERN.
HE WAS MAKING A POINT WITH A
LAUGH THERE BUT IT'S A SERIOUS
ONE.
NEVER FORGET WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT TRUMP STYLE OR TWEETS,
WHATEVER IT IS.
LOOK AT THE RESULTS.
WE HAVE YELLOW BEST PROTESTS IN
FRANCE, WE HAVE THE ONGOING
BREXIT DRAMA, WE HAVE ITALY'S
GOVERNMENT IN COMPLETE CHAOS
MELTDOWN.
GERMANY HEADED ALREADY INTO A
RECESSION.
EUROPE IS IN CHAOS AND YET THE
E.U.'S ATTEMPT AT MANAGING
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISM, WE SEE IT
HAS FAILED MISERABLY.
NOW REMEMBER THAT OBAMA, THE
DARLING OF THE MEDIA ELITES, HE
TRIED HIS BEST TO PUSH A
EUROPEAN STYLE AGENDA HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THAT
WORKED OUT SO WELL THAT HE ENDED
UP TURNING OVER THE WHITE HOUSE
TO DONALD TRUMP.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT ANY PART OF I
IT.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEY ARE
MARKETING THIS MADNESS TO OUR
YOUTH.
ZERO GROWTH, AND IT DESTROYED